[Music]
an NBA all-star weekend has arrived it's
coming to Los Angeles and these weekends
to be a lot of fun and part were the
most popular events of all at the
all-star event now is the slam dunk
contest people love that yeah absolutely
and I've noticed people really love
seeing that they love seen their
favorite players dunk but recently the
last couple of years NBA mascots have
started slam dunk contests and they're
very entertaining they become huge with
the fans take a look
[Music]
it's a lot of good clean fun well we
thought that's great that's fantastic
and good for those mascots but it got me
thinking there are probably plenty of
mascots that should never attempt to
dunk in fact we're going to test my
theory right now by having the first
annual 5 mascots
that should never dunk contest
[Applause]
[Music]
very nice let's get right to it I'm not
sure what teams these mascots before oh
just shut up now first up is a mascot
that has no business dunking the
wireless router let's get the wireless
router in here his little bugger this
router and on your mark get set go
wireless router go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no elegant way to get off that crash way
to get off either the egos in shame
the armless panda ladies and gentlemen
the armless he's going to attempt the
our most pinned is going to attempt an
alley-oop which will fail
let's go armless Panda goo
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it being hustled away that's the saddest
shot right there just stand in shame
with the wireless router okay this is
just a heart this is a mascot who has no
business trying to dunk the old lady
being attacked by Birds
[Applause]
okay go Lady thing attack by bridge go
go
[Applause]
[Music]
she okay
[Applause]
[Music]
now why are you showing this again
here's one here's here the Taco Bell
restaurant you see yes the Taco Bell
and go top of a restaurant go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what we want to see is slow my way
trying to get up
yeah there we go that's more like it
yes my face art is when no one got to
over there to help them right now
and this maybe maybe let's really look
I'd like to see one of these mascots
make it let's hope it's this one finally
two guys in a kayak
[Applause]
and go two guys in a kayak go
[Music]
you want to see them try it again
there's very little time upstream that
guy in front is not helping at all
I got it's Kim Jong Il up front okay
go two guys in a kayak
[Applause]
all right I'm sorry we'd get another
hour from the TBS but we can't afford it
keep it free give it up for these
horrible horrible
[Applause]